(617) 830-4750 is the number.
Let's go to our color.
Why not the five zero two area code?
Let's try five zero two
hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Who's this?
Oh Hey David.
How are you?
I'm Amar from Louisville, Kentucky.
Okay.
Amar.
What's going on?
I'm just calling to see if our, you're going
to political con this year.
You know, I don't have anything to announce
yet with regards to political.
My, my representative is in touch with them.
My understanding is that it's a completely
new staff at Politiken, so there's a lot of
sort of starting from scratch and I don't
have an answer for you right now.
There's a complicated scheduling thing where
I'm at another conference up until the day
before Politiken and so to do it, I'd need
to fly there, not from Boston, but from the
southern conference.
So there's like some logistical things and
they've really got to get sorted out soon.
Otherwise it's going to get too late in the
game.
But are you going, cause it's a Nashville,
so I'm guessing it's close to you in Kentucky.
Yeah, I was.
I'm going in my first time going this year.
I wanted you to see you debate maybe like
Ben Shapiro because I watched a video of when
the first time you talked to him and he kind
of turned into a robot.
Yeah, I thought that was hilarious.
Well, maybe it'll happen, although my sense
is, I don't even know that Ben Shapiro's going
have, has political on announced to anybody
who's going yet.
No, no, no.
I've just been watching, you know, progressive
voice and he's been covering Sam Seutter and
Steven Crowder and all that.
So, uh, I was wondering if you were going.
Got It.
Yeah, no, it's, if I, as soon as I have something
to announce, I will, and if it's determined
that I'm not going for whatever reason, I
will also announce that right now it's just
a question mark.
Okay, awesome.
Thank you, David.
All right.
Amar from Kentucky.
Thank you for the call.